question of mr navalny and his
supporters and honor its international
obligations to respect and ensure human
rights and fundamental freedoms
the russian people like all people have
the right to speak freely
form peaceful associations to common
ends exercise religious freedom and have
their voices heard through free and fair
elections
mr navalny remains imprisoned on
politically fabricated grounds we have
been consistently clear about that
we call again for his immediate and
unconditional release
with that happy to take your questions
thanks
um
i want to start with russia but not with
navalny uh
a couple things they'll be brief
one
do you have any timeline now the white
house punted to you guys when they were
asked when the written response was
going to be sent to
sent to moscow do you
so what i can tell you matt today is
that the response has not yet been
transmitted to moscow but i can assure
you uh that once the response is sent uh
we will let you know so stay tuned so
and and you'll also be giving it to us
as well so we will we will let you know
so stay tuned
we will let you know on a timely basis
secondly yesterday i believe you said
something about how over the past course
of the past week or 10 days or so
in terms of formulating what the
response is going to be
that you were consulting with nato
allies european you know the partners
and allies and i just wanted to know is
does that include ukraine has have
ukrainian officials been consulted about
what this response is going to be and
are you taking into account their
concerns or considerations
in the document yes and yes
we have been consulting extensively with
our allies and our partners and of
course uh when it comes to the latter
court ladder category that includes
ukraine uh we have not only informed
them uh and given them a preview of what
will be in this report but we have
actually explicitly solicited their
feedback and incorporated uh that
feedback into our report so there will
be no surprises there will be no
surprises for nato there will be no
surprises for our european allies uh
there will be no no surprises for our
ukrainian partners and there'll be no
surprises for us or the russians either
we have been
also very clear with all of you because
you have heard us uh consistently say uh
what the
areas where
diplomacy and dialogue uh may prove
fruitful and viable uh and the areas
that are just non-starters you know i i
take it from your from your questions
that there's a perception that uh that
we have been less transparent uh than uh
or might be less transparent than uh the
other side than the russians in this
case what i would say is that uh the
russians have held out one criterion uh
and that is uh their demands when it
comes to nato uh and open door and we've
been very clear about that but
we have also been very clear about
specific areas whether it's the
placement of offensive missiles
whether it is transparency
whether it is exercises whether it is
broader arms control measures where if
done on a reciprocal basis
there is the potential to enhance
collective transatlantic and broader
security uh those are areas where we've
been very clear that we're willing to
engage in dialogue we have been uh
consistently transparent uh with all of
you just as we have conveyed this very
clearly and consistently to the russian
federation there wasn't any implication
in my question but let me just ask this
i mean is there going to be anything in
there that the russians aren't already
aware of that are your positions you
will have to ask the russians when they
uh see the response because it sounds as
though
there won't be anything in there that's
a surprise which means that it's kind of
a you know a document that is kind of a
dead letter right well look if you're
pointing to the fact that uh we have
been very clear both in public
uh and in private uh with the russian
federation with the russian federation
in the strategic stability dialogue uh
with the russian federation in secretary
blinkens meeting with his counterpart
foreign minister lavrov last week with
the russian federation in the context of
the nato-russia council with the russian
federation in the context of the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe the osce yes we
have been very clear uh about the areas
where we believe dialogue and diplomacy
has the potential uh to enhance our
collective security we've also been very
clear about the areas that for us are
just non-starters for us that would be
fundamental violations of the founding
principles of of nato and other uh
foundational uh security instruments
that have protected enhanced promoted uh
unprecedented most
security stability prosperity uh
for the past
70 years
um
so
you will have to ask the russians for
their response once they
see
our written report but uh you are
correct in in one regard we have been
very clear and consistent uh about areas
where diplomacy and dialogue uh may be
fruitful in areas where we are sincerely
and steadfastly uh interested in
engaging in that diplomacy in areas
where for us it's just anonymous last
one um this morning one of your
colleagues over at the white house on a
background call
said that if it gets down to the point
where you're going to impose sanctions
a quote will start at the top of the
escalation ladder
and stay there
and i'm just wondering
is that a wise thing to do to start at
the very top so that the only thing
the only thing more that you could do
would be to would be some kind of
military action
let me um take a step back and and
answer that question this way um first
you have heard from us
consistently you've also heard this
consistently in the category of things
we've been consistent about
that if any russian forces move
across the ukrainian border if there's a
renewed invasion
it will be met with a swift severe and
united response not only from the united
states
uh but also from uh our allies uh and
partners uh we have spoken consistently
about uh
the fact that that swift severe and
united response uh will be unprecedented
that it will entail measures that we
intentionally eschewed in the past uh
including in 2014 uh when russia uh last
invaded uh ukraine uh but it also will
be unprecedented in its approach and
this is the point that you were getting
too mad it's the point that one of my
colleagues uh made this morning my
colleagues said that and you quoted it
partially the gradualism of the past is
out and this time we'll start at the top
of the escalation ladder and stay there
my question is this so if you're at the
top of the escalation ladder
and something else happens
uh
you don't have any further to climb on
the ladder you either fall off or i
guess maybe you jump onto the roof if
the ladder is attached to something but
i don't understand is it really
is it smart to start at the at
by by going all out with nothing left in
reserve i mean are you saying that
whatever you guys and should it become
necessary that whatever you guys will
impose in terms of sanctions
can't be
topped you you have to recall because if
if they can be and if there are steps
that you're not going to take then
you're not starting at the top of the
escalation ladder a couple points
one you have to recall
what this is about and what's at stake
here uh if if this swift severe and
united response goes into effect and let
me be clear we hope it need not have to
we hope that dialogue and diplomacy can
help us find a way out of this help us
find a way to de-escalation and
ultimately to a peaceful resolution of
this russian aggression but if we get
there what we will be talking about is
renewed a renewed russian invasion of
ukraine and the stakes of that as we
talked about yesterday are important in
the context of ukraine of course a close
partner
of the united states a sovereign
independent country uh itself uh and
that of course is important to us it's
important um beyond ukraine as well
the
what should be invaluable rules of the
rules-based international order would
come under assault they would be
undermined
they would be potentially eroded if the
international community were not to
take
drastic steps to show vladimir putin to
show the russian federation that this is
not the kind of action that can be
tolerated in the 21st century these are
the kinds of actions that we sought to
relegate to the dustbin of history after
the second world war uh and if vladimir
putin thinks that uh he
renewed aggression won't be met with uh
severe
swift united response
uh
he
he would be wrong
there's there's another point uh here
that
uh i i think is important though
even
in the
even in the current phase even in recent
weeks
we have seen financial markets
price in a greater risk premium uh into
russian financial assets uh amid the
increasing movement of troops uh
it is not just us that is warning of
this swift severe and united response uh
financial markets private sector actors
uh are
taking note
uh the russian ruble recently hit its
weakest level in over a year versus
the dollar uh and it's the worst
performing emerging market currency so
far this year uh russian sovereign
borrowing costs in terms of the 10-year
bonds they have increased to their
highest levels
since 2016.
russia's stock market has sunk to its
lowest levels
in a year
but the other point and and market
participants know this
is that
what we're seeing now
is nothing compared uh to what would
befall the russian federation the
russian economy if russia's evasion
invasion were to go forward
to your point matt
i just want to be clear about this this
is not about
this is not about um
this is not about punishment uh this is
right now about deterrence uh we are
seeking to do everything we can in the
aft in in the in the prelude to what
could be uh additional russian
aggression to deter
a further russian
invasion of ukraine uh that is why it
behooves us to be crystal clear with
um
the russian federation with vladimir
putin
about the severe costs and consequences
that would befall him that would befall
his country if he were to go forward
with this it doesn't do us any good uh
to pull punches uh to um be ambiguous uh
to be obscure in terms of what we're
talking about and for more than two
months now uh we've tried to be very
clear about that andrea
things
francis macron said today that he will
be talking to vladimir putin on friday
is that helpful uh
does that undercut
the
u.s
lavrov
talks or any talks at a higher level you
know where mixed messages could be
conveyed
um germany
to my knowledge based on what german
officials are saying have not yet
authorized the estonian transfer of
artillery
is the delay in making that decision
tended to tantamount to banning by not
getting it their potential
is that tantamount to not approving it
because of the delay
um
and
the ukrainians you know are saying you
know zelinski said to his people
uh nothing is imminent you can sleep
don't pack your bags don't worry
how does that
you know how do you synchronize that
with
the warnings from the white house
that an invasion could be imminent could
come at any time you know is there a
disconnect between us and the ukrainian
government in terms of our approach
there are reports in fact
from the ground that ukrainians feel
left out of
the diplomacy despite all of your
you know what the pres the secretary's
visit last week and all of your
arguments that nothing about ukraine
without ukraine
let me try and take those uh in order
first on um the the french uh proposal
to engage in dialogue and diplomacy with
the russian federation uh i would remind
everyone precisely what we heard
from nato from the osce from our
european allies uh they're very positive
very warm reaction to the fact that the
united states in full consultation with
nato with the osce uh with our european
allies uh with the ukrainians uh as of a
couple weeks ago uh planned to sit down
in the context of the strategic
stability dialogue the engagement that
our deputy secretary of state wendy
sherman led uh in geneva they have been
very supportive
of our bilateral engagements uh with uh
now more recently foreign minister
lavrov and they've been supportive for i
would say primarily one reason and that
one reason is the fact that we have done
all of this in full coordination in full
consultation with them and that said
just to that point just this week macron
said that the eu
should have its own conversations with
russia and and uh just as
our partners and allies have welcomed
our coordinated consultative engagements
with the russian federation we would
certainly welcome dialogue and diplomacy
uh that could serve to de-escalate uh in
which the russian federation engage
engages in good faith
we would be behind anything that would
serve to
de-escalate tensions in a genuine way uh
that is precisely why we have uh engaged
uh
multilaterally and also bilaterally
again in full consultation and
coordination with our partners and
allies
with uh the russian federation
there are two paths
you've heard us say this before there's
the path of diplomacy and dialogue
there's the path of defense and
deterrence we are pursuing both paths
simultaneously uh knowing that we have
to be ready for either decision that
vladimir putin makes uh if
and we know uh the fact that our uh
allies and partners are engaged in
diplomacy and dialogue to us that's a
good thing
but it is incumbent in all of this on
the russian federation to take steps to
demonstrate that dialogue and diplomacy
are viable uh that they are a means to
an end this is not talking for the sake
of talking uh this is talking sitting
down in a principled clear-eyed way
in an effort to de-escalate tensions and
peacefully resolve uh what the russian
federation has needlessly provoked uh
we're engaged in that our allies and
partners are engaged in that we're
engaging that together multilaterally
through nato and the osce
uh when it comes to our german allies we
talked a bit about this yesterday
um
we were in berlin
last week and the secretary had an
opportunity to speak to chancellor
schultz had an opportunity to uh meet
with foreign minister berbach i the
foreign minister was asked
almost precisely this very question
standing next to secretary blinken and
she spoke in detailed terms
about the important forms of support
that our german allies are showing
to
our ukrainian partners and i say our
because
they are
close partners of both the united states
and germany not to mention all of the
nato allies so different allies are
contributing different elements
to this effort to
reassure to reinforce to deter
further russian
aggression the key
is that all of these forms of support
are reinforcing so whether it is the
fact that the united states for our part
has provided more than 650 million
dollars in security assistance in the
last year the mo the more than in any
previous year uh in history uh whether
it is the fact that secretary blinken
himself has expedited and authorized uh
the third country transfers that uh you
have spoken to uh whether it is uh the
reinforcements that uh my colleague at
the pentagon has spoken to uh in in
recent days we are making important
contributions not only to uh the
defensive security needs of ukraine but
also to the reassurance efforts uh when
it comes to nato's so-called eastern
flank uh our allies are very much doing
the same uh different allies are
contributing in different ways in a way
that is mutually reinforcing and then
finally your question about
uh what we're hearing from our ukrainian
partners look i would make the point
that uh now is not the time for panic
now is the time for preparation that is
precisely what we're doing we have been
clear about our concerns we have been
clear about the depth of those concerns
you
all know why you all know our reasoning
uh that reasoning is is clear given what
we're seeing on uh ukraine's borders
what we're seeing in what should be an
independent sovereign country of belarus
with the russian military build up there
uh what we're seeing with preparations
for potential hybrid operations
all of this is cause for concern uh but
certainly no one is calling for panic
but just just to follow up because
precisely i didn't get an answer on
germany
different countries
participate in different ways
uh is it helpful if germany prevents
estonia
from helping to arm
ukraine
or does it undermine
the unity of the alliance the alliance
is united there is no question uh about
this the alliance is united you have
heard this uh in the form of
communicates and statements from the
alliance itself you don't have to you
don't have to take my word why would
germany stop
artillery from going to ukraine
countries
countries have different authorities uh
different um
uh
different norms different traditions uh
this country what i can speak to is what
we're doing uh and what we are doing is
providing unprecedent unprecedented
levels of defensive security assistance
uh to our ukrainian partners in a way
that uh we've we've done in the past
just on a scale uh that is unprecedented
did the u.s object
to the to them not
to them
imposing this ban
if they do if they do
has the u.s ask them to not interfere we
have had in-depth conversations uh with
all of our nato allies uh about the
deterrent measures that uh we are
prepared to take about the response the
swift severe united response uh that we
are prepared to take our nato allies
know precisely what we are doing um the
steps that you've just many of the steps
you've just heard me detail uh in terms
of our provision of defensive security
assistance to
ukraine in terms of uh the
reinforcements that we are making and
prepared to make uh to nato's
eastern flank different nato allies are
contributing in different uh and
meaningful ways
francesco thank you just to follow up on
andrea's question on
macron's
engagement
you're saying that everything you've
done
was made in coordination with your
partners and allies would you say that
macron talking with putin is done in
coordination with the us
look the level of coordination between
uh our french allies uh in the united
states has been excellent uh i think our
french allies would would say the same
uh as you know they're even in recent
hours have been very high level uh
discussions uh so this conversations
this these consultations uh have been uh
constant and inconsistent uh so
we feel that we have uh
a good sense of what the alliance what
our allies uh are doing and we we know
uh that we've been fully transparent
with our allies and partners and justice
communication is better than it was over
august
is that was that a question or was that
a uh
a job
just a a quick one uh on the the
president said during his press
conference he kind of acknowledged that
um ukraine is not going it's not very
likely that ukraine is going to join
nato in the next upcoming years
uh is this an acknowledgement you're
ready to put in written in your written
response
just saying
we don't shut the doors but it's not
likely that ukraine is going to join in
the upcoming future francesca we've
consistently made the point uh
when we talk about the foundational
inviolable principles
uh one of them when it comes to european
security uh is the right of sovereign
nations to choose their partnerships and
alliances in any way uh that
they see fit
uh
it is written into nato's charter uh
that
countries can aspire to join the
alliance of course
there are a set of membership
requirements uh those membership
requirements uh are clearly spelled out
clearly delineated uh it is the
obligation responsibility of each
aspirant country uh to be in a position
to fulfill those requirements
but nato's door must always remain open
to those aspirant countries that fulfill
those requirements that wasn't my
question my question is are you ready to
take the quote from president biden in
his press conference the likelihood that
ukraine is going to join nato in the
near term is not very likely
are you ready to take that quote and put
it in written in your written response
an open door is an open door that door
will always be open we're not going to
take any move we're not going to say
anything uh that would president just do
we i i don't i don't think the president
did i think
the
the president said exactly what i
reiterated just now that nato accession
is predicated on a set of requirements
that each aspirant country must fulfill
[Music]
just because we're
focused on this written response right
now um
i know you aren't going to preview
exactly you know what this is going to
say but for our expectation purposes
will this written response speak in
broad terms that you have already made
very public about the ideas that the u.s
sees for the u.s and russia potentially
working together
on strategic you know stability and the
like or will it have specific ideas
specific proposals that are on the table
for negotiation's sake
i think the answer to that is both uh
we've been very clear about the areas
in which there may be some uh utility
and where progress can achieve be
achieved
when it comes to enhancing transatlantic
security when it comes to enhancing uh
collective security when it comes to
addressing uh some of the concerns uh
that russia has put forward uh and so in
the discussions with foreign minister
lavrov and the discussions with
deputy foreign minister yapkov and the
discussions
at nato and the discussions with the
osce
there have been
broad
high-level discussions about
various principles including uh
the principle we've just discussed here
but then there have also been uh more
tactical discussions uh discussions
about um
the placement of missiles uh discussions
about
reciprocal steps steps vis-a-vis uh
exercises about confidence-building
measures about transparency uh about
broader arms control uh so
the universe in which we can
engage diplomatically or at least in
which we can engage diplomatically
and potentially achieve some progress
we've outlined
what that universe looks like the
russians know that we've done that
together with our allies and partners uh
and the written response will do that as
well
right so are we expecting that there
should be uh a bit more filled into that
outline in this written response than we
have seen publicly
uh
the what the
written response will reflect
uh is
uh what we have said
and that is the fact that there are
certain areas uh that for us are
non-starters uh and there are other
areas uh where
dialogue and diplomacy has the potential
to enhance uh collective transatlantic
security and uh also account for some of
the concerns that that russia has made
uh i don't want to get ahead of a report
that uh written response that we haven't
formally transmitted yet
but again we
have
been entirely
clear
about what those universes are where
that venn diagram of russia's stated
concerns our stated concerns the
concerns of
nato of our european allies of our
ukrainian partners we've been clear that
there is
an overlapping element of that venn
diagram and that's what we're talking
about here in terms of pursuing
dialogue uh in diplomacy on the path
towards
de-escalation and hopefully a peaceful
resolution
of this needless
russian aggression that is a proposition
we're prepared to continue to test
we'll have to see what uh how the
russians respond what the next steps
might be
but the next step will be transmitting
uh that response to the russian
federation yes
thank you just to be clear your answer
to francesco
was no you will not be including
a um
a characterization of the likelihood or
not of ukraine joining nato you see open
doors and
so i would say a couple things um one an
open door is an open door uh two uh our
response to the russian federation uh
was drafted and and is being drafted
in full consultation and coordination
and transparency with our
european allies and ukrainian partners
but it is a u.s response so uh it is not
for the united states to speak to nato's
posture uh in any written response that
we put forward
so i think for a couple reasons uh that
is not the kind of thing i would expect
to see in any written response from the
united states okay when you talk about
it not yet being transmitted are you
also saying it's not yet fully drafted
even though because you keep saying that
you're consulting still even though you
also are saying that it's everything we
already know and it's said so you are
still drafting as well as not having i i
don't want to characterize it's it's
state of completion i will say that um
uh you know secretary blinken was clear
that it will be transmitted this week so
i would just say stay tuned
it will be a us government response
i'd love to ask
you and your colleagues sometimes talk
about diplomacy and dialogue on the one
side defense and deterrence on the other
but and you know with president putin
kind of deciding in the middle like
like some kind of magic eight ball or
something but we're seeing signs on the
ground uh you know you mentioned the the
moax stock exchange the ruble weakness
you know we've seen troops going into
belarus
we've seen nato directing troops toward
us eastern flank does that mean that the
scope for diplomacy has has narrowed
what it means is that we haven't seen
the de-escalation that is necessary
if diplomacy and dialogue is to prove
successful uh
we've been very clear that uh as we
always are uh that
there is not a precondition uh for
dialogue uh and diplomacy uh but there
is a precondition uh for that dialogue
and diplomacy uh
moving in the right direction uh and
moving towards the end state that we
hope to see and that precondition is
de-escalation is it moving in the right
direction or the wrong direction i mean
things really stand still in this world
well i i don't think that we've seen any
concrete indications of de-escalation
just yet
yes
anything else on russia ukraine
sure yeah um you were talking about the
unity among allies um i wonder if you
wanted to respond to the
uh
croatian president uh
milonovic
uh who said croatia would in no way be
involved in this crisis if it's
escalated and they will you know
specifically said we'll recall croatian
troops uh from nato um
deployment so you know
what is there is there real
uh unity among your allies on this
i think uh you have seen the unity that
has been expressed uh in formal
statements uh from nato from the g7
from
the
osce from the european commission
that speaks to
uh the unity that we have
forged uh not in recent days but really
in in over the past couple months this
is something that we have been hard at
work at since we first started speaking
to this
in early november if i recall
this is something that
as our uh
as the information picture has uh
developed we have consistently shared
information
with allies and partners we have engaged
with our allies and partners in any
number of fora
both in person whether it was last month
at the g7
whether it was
at the nato ministerial whether it was
at the osce uh we have done so uh over
the phone uh as well video conferences
uh well over a hundred engagements uh as
of earlier this month
with our
european allies uh and our partners as
well of course uh including ukraine uh
and that extends to uh last week when we
were again in kiev we had an opportunity
to meet with president zielinski had an
opportunity to meet with foreign and
that engagement has continued since of
course the secretary has had an
opportunity to speak to the foreign
minister after uh his meeting with
foreign minister lavrov uh to back brief
him uh on that engagement because again
we are operating with the core principle
in mind and that is nothing about
without nothing about ukraine without
ukraine about europe without europe
about nato without nato
specifically on croatia
you know are you concerned that
countries are signing up to formal
statements when and then on the other
side making these kind of comments that
they they don't actually support what i
can point to are the formal statements
that nato allies have signed you're not
concerned at all
if
the commander-in-chief of a country is
then saying something completely opposed
to what they've signed and supposedly
signed up
documents are um
a physical manifestation of the
commitments that uh uh that the allies
have made i can point you to those
documents and if it comes to you know uh
john fina
deputy national security adviser john
peyton has said that nato will make
decisions about possible troop movements
you know we talked about there's no um
daylight on the sanctions response but
what about on potentially deploying uh
nato troops you know are you concerned
that there isn't the same level of unity
perhaps uh when it comes to that
military
aspect on the eastern flank not ukraine
the alliance has been very clear just as
uh the united states has been very clear
uh about our commitment to reassure to
reinforce uh the eastern flank certainly
uh if there is renewed aggression uh if
there is a military invasion but as you
heard us say yesterday uh we've never
said that uh even in the absence of that
we wouldn't take prudent steps
to
provide that reinforcement and
reassurance but i will leave it to the
nato alliance to speak to the specifics
of those plans
joel
a couple of questions on both the
diplomatic and deterrence piece um
the the baltic states of course
announced last week that they will be
providing anti-armor and anti-aircraft
weapons um and secretary blinken
emphasized that he approved this um
do you think that's an adequate upgrade
of ukraine's anti-aircraft defenses or
are you considering any other more
substantial reinforcements
well uh
what
you're referring to um is part and
parcel of a much larger effort on the
part of uh various countries uh around
the world including many in the in the
nato alliance uh to
provide additional defensive uh security
assistance to ukraine uh you've heard me
say this already today but for our part
the united states has uh provided more
than 650 million dollars in the last
year in defensive security assistance
more so than any uh previous year the
200 million dollars in additional
security assistance that was approved
last month i believe the second delivery
of which uh arrived uh overnight etf uh
so you can speak to what uh our all our
baltic allies are doing you can speak to
what other european allies are doing you
can speak to what the united states is
doing and the totality of that
is should send a clear signal to
the russian federation or any other
aggressor
that ukraine's partners
are
providing and prepared to provide uh
ukraine with what it needs to defend
itself right i just i've heard questions
should that should we expect more
stingers to go to ukraine than the than
the batch announced and or or even
patriots uh any anything to
obviously there's an imbalance of air
you know russian air capability so what
i would say is that the second
installment i believe of that uh of the
deliveries associated with the 200
million that was approved last month in
december
by president biden those deliveries will
continue in the coming days and coming
weeks you saw
that there were pictures and imagery uh
broadcast of that delivery uh overnight
and i expect you'll um be hearing more
about subsequent deliveries of defensive
uh security assistance uh in the days
and weeks to come we've provided some
details uh of that i believe uh last
weekend we spoke to 200 000 pounds of
ammunition uh that was provided to our
ukrainian partners uh but we're of
course not detailing uh all elements of
that defensive security assistance we're
providing uh on the diplomatic side um
you know the french have talked about
sort of reviving the normandy format or
or
to some extent um
do you see the implementation of minsk
two as a diplomatic off-ramp from this
this threat of new of a new invasion
um and would that require ukraine
to uh
to move towards some kind of special
status for donbass
uh before a
recovering control of its border there
minsk is an important uh road map it's
an important ingredient uh we see full
implementation of the minsk chords
as an important uh way forward it's also
a fact that there's one country
that has
been the primary violator
of the minsk agreements and that one
country is russia
you heard secretary blinken in the osce
in stockholm last month uh delineate
almost line by line uh the various
elements of those uh agreements that the
russian federation has not lived up to
uh in all of our engagements uh with
russia the united states our native
allies uh we have made clear the
importance of full implementation of the
minsk agreements uh and again there is
one uh core violator of those agreements
yes
uh so your pentagon uh counterpart said
yesterday that the us is ready to send
more capabilities to the eastern flank
countries independently of nato uh if
they need it he said that and
these countries have been pretty open
about uh their desire for an increased
us presence so does that mean that it's
basically a done deal and when might we
expect a decision
and a
second if i may
uh the belarusian uh dictator um
alexander olgashanka felt necessary uh
recently to stress that he will not
allow any occupation of belarus
presumably by the russian forces that
are
coming which of course you know uh
prompted concerns that
this is in fact what might happen
uh and there have been concerns about
that are you concerned about uh such a
scenario of russian forces occupying
basically occupying belarus
uh so to start with your first question
i know my pentagon counterpart and
predecessor has spoken to this in in
recent days he's spoken to
the number of service members at a
heightened state of readiness and
contextualize the fact that this order
will ensure
that they are a heightened
preparedness to deploy and provide
support
should they be called upon but it was
also clear uh that they have not uh been
active activated uh for uh deployments
these are the types of decisions uh that
will uh be made as an alliance uh as uh
the the full uh nato alliance so i would
defer to my pentagon counterpart in to
nato
to speak to the next steps
he also said that
the u.s might send
additional capabilities independently of
that
nato response force
uh if if the if there's a need uh and he
said that he
the u.s is open to provide that
so
is that i mean
baltic states and poland have been
pretty open that they they want this
increased presence i i will leave it to
my pentagon counterpart uh to speak to
uh potential uh
uh deployment of service members they've
they've spoken extensively to this uh
yesterday and in recent days when it
comes to belarus we have been um
clearly voicing
our concerns uh with
the military buildup in what should be
an independent sovereign country uh
rus russia's
uh surging of troops into belarus um is
a cause for for deep concern
the
that surge as i alluded to a moment ago
uh threatens
sovereignty
it undermines its status in some ways as
an independent country
we also know that belarus has been an
increasingly destabilizing actor in the
region you need to look no further
than
the lukashinka regime's attempts to
cruelly
weaponize the flow of
innocent migrants the migrant crisis
that the regime orchestrated
and the other point i would make
is that just as we've been clear with
the russian federation about the
severe costs that would uh befall them
were this to move forward uh in recent
days we've also made clear to belarus
that if it allows its territory to be
used for an attack on ukraine it would
face a swift and decisive response
from the united states uh and our allies
uh and partners
we would if an invasion were to proceed
from uh belarus if uh russian troops
were to permanently station uh on their
territory uh nato could well uh have to
reassess our own force posture in the
countries that border belarus but to
your question
the
permission structure that the lukashinka
regime has provided to vladimir putin to
station
a large number of russian troops on what
should be sovereign belarusian soil
that is an affronts of belarus of
sovereignty
it is another indication that this is a
regime
that has little regard for its own
people
uh little regard for
uh the state uh and the most regard uh
for
the survival the welfare of the regime
itself
uh one more question on russia ukraine
sure
does the u.s have any indication
that russia will refrain from invading
ukraine during the beijing olympic which
is february 4 to 20th one who argue like
why would russian president putin want
to upset
chinese president xi jinping at the time
when they need each other much more than
in 2008
that's that's a question that is better
posed to vladimir putin uh it is not up
to us uh to try to divine try to uh
predict uh what he may or may not do uh
it is however uh a simple historical
fact as secretary blinken alluded to a
couple days ago uh that a previous uh
summer olympic games i was it was if i
recall uh did not prevent vladimir putin
from going into uh another independent
country so i think all that says you'll
have to ask uh vladimir putin one value
because in 2008 uh chinese leader ujin
tao has a different relationship with
the putin and now is a citizen chinese
in power he has a different relationship
with putin and that many things have
changed so would you
you just said that it's not a time to
panic is there any indication
um diplomacy will prevail during that
paper time is there any indication that
that um
russia will refrain from
further military escalation
that's a question you'd have to you'd
have to pose to russia yes
uh yesterday you started do you open up
the briefing condemning the houthis
attack on uae and saudi arabia
um and you said that putting them back
on the terror list is under review can
you just explain to us what does under
review mean it's just like you want to
see them more engaged in terrorist
attack is it a legal issue
what does it mean and some reports
indicating that both the pentagon and
the cia are actually um agreeing that
they should be put back on the terror
list because they threaten international
water world economy etc so what does
under view means
under review just means that it's
something that we are taking a close
look at internally within the u.s
government
to determine what would best
serve our national security interests
what would best serve our desire
to
be a partner to
saudi arabia to the uae to other
countries that are threatened by
these houthi attacks
what would also
allow us to best serve our interest in
bringing an end uh to this civil war in
yemen that has not only wrought horrific
violence and instability across the
country but has led to
uh a humanitarian catastrophe if i
recall there are more than 16 million
yemenis uh who are uh suffering from
food insecurity uh and so we're taking
uh all of this and more into account uh
as we determine uh the next best steps
um
we will continue to work with our allies
and partners in the region especially
to promote accountability for
the houthis for those houthi leaders
that have been behind these terrorist
attacks we have done this
in recent weeks in recent months using a
variety of tools
including
sanctions i
would venture to guess you will see
additional uh steps on our part to hold
to account uh those houthi leaders who
are responsible for uh these
reprehensible attacks as i said
yesterday uh we're not going to relent
in designating uh houthi leaders and
entities involved in military offensives
that threaten civilians
that
threaten regional stability that
perpetuate the cut the conflict those
who are responsible for some of the
human rights abuses or the violations of
international humanitarian law
or that exacerbate the humanitarian
crisis when you talk about the
humanitarian crisis
uh there is one actor that is primarily
responsible for the suffering
of the many people the widespread
suffering of the many people uh and that
is that is the houthis uh so we are
using uh every appropriate tool and we
will continue to use every appropriate
tool uh to hold the houthis uh to
account
okay i have two more questions on iran
um the former prisoners who have been
held in jail iran went on hunger strike
in vienna as you know
and rob mali issued a statement they
wanted basically uh to make sure that
the release of u.s hostages in iran is
preconditioned to negotiation with with
the iranian regime
um the iranians said they're adamant
that that's not going to be linked so
despite your commitment to that how
you're going to
deal with with the fact that iran
refused to to
discuss the release of the
prisoners
and give assurance to their families
that you're doing everything to make
sure that they are released
uh so let me spend a moment just on um
barry rosen one of the former uh uh
embassy hostages uh you referenced uh
and you heard us welcome uh the end of
uh mr rosen's hunger strike and we
applaud his heroic efforts uh to
um secure to help secure the release of
all foreign and dual nationals held by
iran
this is
a challenge that continues to have to
your question our our full attention um
barry rosen
his colleagues they are their heroes um
and that's why uh special envoy mali uh
met with mr rosen in vienna uh and will
of course meet with him again uh at any
time to hear his important perspective
to to hear his thoughts uh we are deeply
moved by his commitment
to the release of those american
citizens and third country nationals who
are wrongfully
detained in iran it's a commitment that
we completely share
you heard from the special envoy that uh
we are continuing to pursue separate uh
indirect talks uh with iran to secure
the release of uh those who are unjustly
uh held by
the regime
you have
heard us make the point that
it would not serve our interest it
certainly would not serve the interests
of the americans and third country
nationals who are unjustly held in iran
to tie their fates
to
a proposition
that is at best uncertain and that is
the proposition of a mutual return to
compliance with the jcpoa
that is a proposition that is at best
uncertain we want the return of
americans and these third country
nationals to be
a certainty uh that is our goal to bring
them home to reunite them with their
families
and so of course we do not want to
have anything unnecessarily stand in the
way so we'll continue to treat these
issues uh as uh separate
as we strive to secure their release
again one more on iran
this is any division within the
negotiation team in vienna i mean is
muslim nephew or um in agreement with
your policy
or does he disagree that the way you're
handling imposing the sanction on iran
the way you want to implement it is
different than that of rob mali and
others
well unfortunate to say that richard
nephew is still
a member of
the state department team uh he no
longer serves as
the deputy special envoy for iran but as
you know a year into an administration
uh personnel moves are um
are common uh of course we're not going
to get into the specific sensitive time
it's common for them to leave when they
negotiate in a deal that it's hinged on
getting back to this agreement well look
i'm not going to comment on the
specifics of any uh decision uh of
someone to take a step back from a
particular account but you've seen
across the administration uh that
especially at this time a year into the
administration uh there have been a
number of personnel moves uh across a
variety of fronts including uh on on
high profile uh issues uh the the the
fact is and i think the broader context
here
is that the previous administration um
we've been clear about this left us with
a terrible set of options uh
the
maximum pressure campaign uh was an
abject failure everything that it
promised the opposite
ended up coming true whether it was
promises of a better deal whether it was
promises of a subdued iran a cowed set
of proxies uh and uh terrorist
uh affiliates uh whether it was
putting the brakes on iran's
nuclear program whether it was
bringing together the world
to
bring about
maximalist demands on
iran
across all of those areas the opposite
uh came true uh we inherit uh iranian
angler program uh that was galloping
head that has continued uh to gallop
ahead and an iranian nuclear program
that was not subject unfortunately uh to
the most stringent verification and
monitoring regime ever negotiated uh and
uh verification and monitoring regime
that was
working and verifiably so
working according to
the state department working according
to our intelligence community working
according to the iaea uh working
according to
uh our allies uh and partners so having
inherited a very difficult and
challenging terrible even set of options
we've said about a path that uh we
believe uh is in our uh
national security interest and that is a
mutual return to compliance with the
jcpoa it's a a path that uh up until now
uh has been in our estimation uh the
best way to once again put those uh
stringent permanent verifiable
limitations on iran's uh nuclear program
but we've been equally clear uh that
there will come a day uh and there will
come a day uh soon
when uh the non-proliferation benefits
that the jcpoa promised uh in 2015 and
that were implemented in 2016 uh will be
uh watered down and eroded by the
advancements that iran has made
since the last administration left the
deal uh in its nuclear program so uh
right now we are still um
seeking to achieve a mutual return to
compliance uh but we're weighing all
options and weighing alternatives
very quickly uh what happened since
yesterday and when the foreign minister
iranian foreign minister said they were
open to direct talks have you reached
indirectly out to them saying okay
you're open we're open let's do this now
and
and and just meet well i wouldn't want
to uh speak to um anything like that but
you know it would not take us reaching
out for the iranians to know uh
precisely uh
where we are uh and what we have uh long
preferred uh we've been very clear just
about just to organize a national
meeting well um we
again uh we have uh been open to uh
sitting down directly uh with our uh
allies and partners uh with the iranians
since this uh began last april uh i
believe it was so uh it is up to the
iranians to make good uh on that
statement we do believe uh that it'll be
more more productive to uh engage
directly with iran um when it comes to
jcpoa when it comes to uh other issues
uh it would also enable more efficient
communication and that is what we need
especially at this moment when we have
precious little time left
in an effort to try and salvage uh or to
effect a mutual return to compliance
with the jcpoa
so nothing has happened since yesterday
nothing else to announce
sure
so uh uh back in september the secretary
made this designation that he was going
to withhold or you would that the us was
not going to spend this 130 million uh
foreign military financing
unless egypt met certain conditions a
couple hours ago several democratic
congress people
wrote to the secretary asking him not to
certify that those conditions have been
met
um
and i don't know
if that such a determination has been
met
but i do notice
that just a few minutes ago
you guys announced 2.5 billion dollars
in arms sales to egypt
is any of that 2.5 billion part of the
130 million and foreign i mean that
2.5 billion is
astronomically more than 130 million
right
so matt you won't be surprised to hear
me say that we don't comment on
congressional correspondence we don't
have anything
new to announce when it comes to
the fmf and the decision that was made
in september that you referenced
what i can say now um is that we may
have more to say uh in the coming days
but uh what you've already heard us say
um remains the case that uh we remain
committed to engaging uh with our
egyptian partners on on human rights uh
we um have consistently emphasized that
uh our bilateral relationship would be
strengthened uh by
uh
tangible improvement uh and respect for
human rights and fundamental freedom so
you can't say whether this 130 million
is part of the 2.5 billion
uh if we have anything to add on that
we'll get right to you well i i just
want to what is the point of holding
withholding 130 million in foreign
military financing
when you're just going to turn around
and sell them
2.5 billion
in weapons
matt if we if we have anything to add on
on that uh on on the report you're
referencing we'll let you know it's a
report it's an announcement from pm
let you know
sure
made any um progress on human rights in
the last year
i you know we have spoken to uh steps
that
uh have been welcomed that we have
welcomed
but
this is a dialogue that is ongoing uh
and we've consistently made the point uh
that as we have seen progress uh on
individual cases uh that um
additional progress across the board
would only serve to strengthen our
relationship
our relationship with egypt
is
fundamentally
important across any number of realms
when it comes to
regional security
when it comes to counterterrorism uh and
so of course we would like to see that
relation that relationship strengthened
even more uh and one way to do that is
additional progress in human rights
yes andrea two more cruise missiles
fifth launch and
[Music]
one week
from north korea
but do you have a new policy to try to
get them to answer your messages
well not yours personally
uh you have heard us speak to our
approach to
the dprk
it is a policy that
was formulated in the early days of this
administration
that we
developed in close coordination with our
allies
and partners especially the rok uh and
japan we've had a number of engagements
with them in the trilateral format
knowing the importance of trilateral
cooperation uh when it comes to uh that
ultimate goal and that's the complete
denuclearization of the korean peninsula
we we have also been very clear about uh
our intent uh
number one we have no hostile intents we
harbor no hostile intent uh towards the
dprk we are open to dialogue we're open
to diplomacy we think dialogue and
diplomacy uh is the most effective means
to
help us reach uh that overarching goal
and that's the complete denuclearization
of the
korean peninsula
if you're referring to the reports
overnight we are still assessing uh with
the rok in japan
those reports i don't have any further
details that at this time though
thank you all very much
[Laughter]
you